a young lady named Julia recently found
sketches of the dress that her
grandmother Drew at Fashion School way
back in the 1940s it looks pretty good
her grandmother never did anything with
these drawings on your screen right now
so Julia decided to surprise her and
actually make one of the drawings into a
dress take a look
oh my goodness that is stunning
that is absolutely stunning thank you
that of course is Julia modeling the
dress she made and she says seeing her
grandmother's reaction was worth all the
work
my Grandma she's always been my idol
growing up so getting to bond with her
and connect with her through this
experience has been amazing she has
brought a smile to my face my entire
life growing up so it's a very beautiful
feeling to be able to reciprocate that